Manning with the driver kind of fit you
huh yesterday
so far yeah I changed hats true went to
the yeah no I hat so making New Orleans
get me in the fairway I might stay with
you for a little while
my Peyton's got a good ways in here but
it just kind of depends on where he
wants to leave it cuz in this rain
downwind there's not a whole lot you can
do
awesome shower parts oh yeah I'm a hell
of a shot talk to me
oh wow wow what a shot partner great
shot yeah that's more like it and just
everything I think about is what would
Charles not do I was not thinking there
let's watch Pete and swing though oh my
goodness baby
perfect
oh hey Maddie
Parker just imagine the gallery going
nuts beautiful thing that was for the
win at this par 3/4 and Peyton Manning
Michael Senate Brady two down now Peyton
that's his third
that seems to be on a nice line Wow
Trevor as a great player how hard is it
for a pro I mean it's
for four three in the wind for Peyton
Manning Wow for three and Peyton Manning
has two on the board himself three up
those woods and Manning struggle is real
it's a great shot there by Peyton
now he's useful player he likes that
drawing knows he can rely on it 168
yards hole location
front left well this is good-looking
kick hard come on come on down oh that's
nice our threes are kind of your thing
huh maybe birdie the last part three two
hi to Colorado switch oh it changed it
hat alright so it took Tigers tee shot
Peyton will have the second remember
we're alternate shot here I don't think
I've ever seen team morale higher when
they're three down from Peyton and
they've taken both the Tigers tee shots
twice Peyton has had a green and red
that's got Tiger all smiles
paetynn last to play here with the
driver
nicely done if had to use Tigers tee
shots on the first three alternate shot
holes that'll give them an option here
with Hayden fairway that accurate shot
right out of two great shot Wow all
right still in the game here now Paton
wasted no time
all right what a golf shot that is so
don't worry great shot out of the search
of stances he's really been terrific
into the game good